some breaking news this is with regard  to coronavirus we understand that a  surgery in Northamptonshire has closed  due to a potential coronavirus case the  braclet Medical Center in  Northamptonshire wrote this on their  Facebook page they said due to a  potential coronavirus incident we've had  to close the Washington house site until  the premises is cleaned and cleared as a  precautionary measure we will update as  soon as we can this is coming from an  incident this morning when the Bradley  Medical Center had to close it is not a  confirmed case of coronavirus the  medical centers say they are working  closely with public health England who  are advising us accordingly and please  bear with us at this time we will update  you as soon as we have more information  available so that news just coming in  brightly medical center in  Northamptonshire has been closed due to  a potential corona virus incidents  you